in the Bible in the gospels there really
aren't a lot of hot button issues that
Jesus speaks about really directly and
says listen here's the deal with that
thing he doesn't do that very much
marriage is one of those things though
where he says very directly you CA if
you get divorced and remarried that's
adultery and that is recorded in
multiple gospels him saying that so if
you can just ignore that and say uh yeah
you know um no there's none of that he
said it that's one of the few issues
where we can look at what he said it's
right there so if we're gonna punt that
down the road then
how do you you know you've already given
up the defenses I mean it seems to me
that what happened from a religious and
from a secular perspective is that the
institution of marriage which was always
about the bearing and rearing of
children fundamentally changed into it's
two people who love each other well once
it's two people who love each other
you're at same-sex marriage because it
could be any two people who love each
other it has nothing to do with kids
anymore it has nothing to do with
building a functional Institution